I think Trump just stands in a very long
line of culture warriors who want to
exclude Catholics from the American
family who want to exclude Mormons from
the American family
Stephen prothero is a historian of
American religion his book is why
liberals win the culture wars even when
they lose elections first of all how do
you define culture war what it what is a
culture war and who are these
conservatives and liberals we're talking
about yeah okay good so a culture war as
I understand it is a sort of pitched
battle with a lot of militaristic
rhetoric that's about moral religious
and cultural questions that touches on
the meaning of America so it can't be
just sort of an easygoing disagreement
among friends about something right it
has to have a sense of something really
powerful at stake and typically both
sides in a culture war going to denounce
the other as on American or as even
treasonous or something like that so
that's what culture war is and then the
liberal conservative is tricky because I
do argue that you can track liberals and
conservatives from around 1800 when my
book gets going until the contemporary
times but of course those those terms
change right so you know you have
conservatives who are on one side of an
issue you know early on and then they
end up being on another side of an issue
an issue later but both sides have this
righteous minority kind of feeling that
fuels the culture wars from both the
left and the right but the vast majority
of culture warriors and the most pitched
of them are on the conservative side so
why are liberals always the winners is
there something inherently socially
liberal about the United States well
when I when I started working on this on
this book I actually started thinking
about it with the Ground Zero mosque
controversy a few years ago where where
was this Muslim guy who owned this
property going to be able to build a
Islamic community center near Ground
Zero and I was really surprised that
conservatives were sort of lining up
against this issue where it would seem
like you know religious liberty private
property rights these are sort of
standard conservative things like why
would they be opposed so I started
looking back in American history for
prior culture wars and then I was
researching them I I was surprised
I mean as a historian of religion I
didn't really know this I was like this
is weird the Liberals are winning all
these you sorted in my head I was
thinking well these are battles kind of
evenly fought and like two equal teams
on a football field or something where
in any given day one might win and the
other might lose but it just seemed like
the Liberals kept coming coming on the
on the winning side and I think there is
a way in which the liberal side on
conservative on cultural questions that
is is it does have the Constitution
largely on its side right has the Bill
of Rights on its side in terms of you
know Liberty Liberty for this Liberty
Liberty for that and typically the
culture wars or efforts to restrict our
Liberty rather than to expand our
Liberty so I think that that's part of
it but I think the bigger reason when
liberals win is because conservatives
just pick losing causes why do they do
that why would anyone pick a political
fight that is on the losing side well to
me conservatism from the really the
beginning of American culture has always
been as cultural as it is economic and
on the cultural side of conservatism
there's always been the sense of loss
like something's being lost here and
very early on it was that sort of
looming danger of the French Revolution
that might somehow take away stability
from American culture but throughout
American history there's been sort of a
series of sense of losses that
conservatives have perceived like the
loss of Christian America or the loss of
white control or the loss of patriarchy
or the loss of the traditional family
would it whatever it might be they
attach to issues where their
constituents their cultural
conservatives who listen to them are
going to say yeah that's right you know
that that makes me worried that makes me
fearful I'm afraid of that like you are
you know in the elections today so much
of what's going on in the Republican
primaries is about trying to make us
fearful right these Mexicans are coming
across the border these terrorists are
going to come and blow us up right and
so they picked these issues where
there's a sort of a palpable sense of
fear and anxiety and the reason there is
a palpable sense of fear and anxiety is
because that issue is already going the
other way right why worry about these
gay people getting married when there's
five gay people in America
and no gay people want to get married
right it's when gay people start to be
more visible in the society when they're
starting to push for their own freedom
to marry that you start to get agitated
about that and by the time that's
happening the issues already kind of
going the liberal direction would it be
smart from a winning perspective for
conservatives to say to read your book
first of all and then just say yes hey
wait a minute we should be we should
look at the cultural wars from a
positive way instead of putting this
losing downbeat sort of spin on it so
President Obama ran of course on you
know hope campaign you know yes we can
campaign and this election cycle really
is is running on a fear on the fear side
particularly on the on the Republican
side and you see that with someone like
Marco Rubio who really started with a
hope campaign like I'm the young guy on
the sort of the guy who was going to
bring Hispanics into this you know party
that seems to have gone over to the
white side and passed but as so many of
the voters on in the Republican
primaries are seemingly being drawn to
Cruz and to trump into the sort of the
danger the fear the anxiety side he's
heading he's heading that way too so I
think they're going that way because it
works because that's what matches the
culture war narrative and the culture
war rhetoric and the culture wars work
Trump's anti-immigration rhetoric has
really been turned up over the last few
months saying specifically you know
talking about barring immigration
specifically against Muslims or Syrian
refugees and it's being treated almost
as a new phenomenon in the United States
but you you seem to argue just the
opposite that that Trump's arguments go
way way back in in American history
because this is a particularly the
culture wars as a particularly American
thing I don't think Trump is
unprecedented and I think we sort of
flatter ourselves those of us who are
who feel nervous about trumpism you know
we flatter ourselves by imagining this
is just this outlier but I think Trump
just stands in a very long line of
cultural warriors who want to exclude
Catholics from the American family who
want to exclude Mormons from the
American family and in his case want to
exclude Muslims from the American family
we have a long history of cultural
warfare over immigration the the
anti-immigration acts of the 1920s were
where efforts to get rid of
in Japanese immigration because the idea
was we could never possibly assume and
assimilate these yellow people into
white America so um there's deep veins
there of anxiety and fear about people
who don't look like us that he's that
he's tapping into and I think what's
different about Trump is that he's so
brazen about it and he's so upfront
about it and we're not getting you know
code words and dog whistles were just
getting very explicit what appears to be
you know chauvinistic and exclusivist
and even racist language yeah and his
whole slogan right make America great
again right that plays into the whole
notion of loss that you were talking
about it is right I mean I think his his
campaign is sort of you know we America
has been schlong do you know but it will
be great again you know it's this it's
this again it's this narrative of loss
and recovery
something's been taken away from us and
the presumed us they are as these is
sort of you know white men who are older
who have a sense of the world slipping
away from them as the country is
becoming brown or as women are making
their way into the workforce as the
homes or homes and families are becoming
more egalitarian as religions other than
Christianity are becoming visible in
American public culture all those
changes you mentioned strike me as very
positive things in American history and
I'm wondering why do conservatives look
back 20 30 40 50 years and say oh things
were better then because they have a
different vision of America than your
vision because because for them Liberty
is not as important and I'm on the
cultural conservative side of
republicanism and conservatism is this
idea that you want to protect the
hometown you want to protect the family
you know you want to you want to close
ranks around traditional values you want
to oppose moral relativism you know you
want to save the lives of innocent
children and the unborn right so those
values sometimes work with Liberty
values but sometimes they work against
libertarian values politics and the
Bible for example is not does not really
get mentioned in the same breath and say
England for example it's always a
personal issue for politicians where's
the United States right you must
absolutely talk about prayer and your
personal commitments personal religious
commitments if you're going to be a
politician at any
high level do you think does the Bible
have that kind of place should it have
that kind of place in American political
discourse away from the should question
first
it always has I mean except for maybe at
the very beginning because the beginning
of the United States was really
dominated by these deist types who
really weren't all they certainly
weren't evangelicals and they weren't
particularly Christian many of them so
there was a sort of maybe from your
perspective a kind of brief shining
moment you know when religion just
wasn't that much a part of our public
culture but pretty soon it it was
central and it's all we've always had
this unresolved issue we've had the
unresolved issue of race and we're going
the unresolved issue of religion
throughout American history and the
culture wars are in part an effort to
resolve what the founders didn't resolve
because they did not strictly separate
church and state they they sort of
separated church and state but they
allowed for military chaplains and they
allowed for prayers before you know the
Supreme Court he'll have four prayers
before the opening of the US Congress
you know they allowed for presidents to
declare fast days and days of
Thanksgiving so we had we've always had
this sort of overlay of kind of vaguely
Christian piety that you don't have in
public culture in Europe where to talk
about Jesus while you're running for
prime minister is to be laughed off the
stage and not to get any votes and the
culture war is in some way a part of
what the American identity is part of
that working through the fact that our
founders didn't specify it hope may be
hard enough that that helps to shape the
American identity yeah I mean I think
very something in American identity that
is we are a special project for God most
Americans have believed that throughout
American history you know and you see I
mean Lincoln is kind of a hero of mine
but Lincoln believes that too you know
when he's wrestling in a second
inaugural address for the Civil War and
he's saying you know what you know I
know there's a god I know God is in
charge of history and therefore God
could end the Civil War but God is not
ending this
what the hell is going on you know and
you see him wrestling in that amazing
speech with that and finally he says you
know look we don't understand what's
going on here you know I am a big fan of
the people who don't understand what God
is doing because people who do
understand what God is doing seem to me
the people who are most dangerous in you
know not only American history but in
world history but that said I think most
Americans have had a sense that the u.s.
is a kind of religious project and in
that sense really secular libertarians
who want to say you know that the public
space should be should be totally
stripped of religious conversation those
people are really fighting an uphill
battle so that's an area where liberals
don't always win right they're fighting
this up well that is interesting and I
say that at the end of why Liberals when
I say that that you know conservatives
lose all the culture wars liberals win
all the culture wars and they say but
wait a minute there are a few things in
the contemporary culture wars that
conservatives have won and one of them
is to keep religion in the public space
so so um you know the at least not all
liberals have this view but many
liberals would like to see and certainly
the classic Democratic Party position
has been that church and state should be
separate and that as Thomas Thomas
Jefferson was attacked in the election
of 1800 that write about in the book for
his religion but he didn't respond in
public why because he said religion is a
private matter shouldn't be a part of
elections you know I think we'd be
better if we more if we were more
Jeffersonian in that in that regard but
the Democratic Party has capitulated on
that you know after John Kerry lost the
presidential election
one of the post-mortems was you know he
wasn't good about talking about his
faith he wasn't good about talking about
himself as a Catholic he just he sounded
like someone who really didn't have a
relationship with Jesus that's not that
was a problem in that election yeah and
if he had been able to emote a little
more about his catholicity you know he
might have been he might have been
elected elected president so we now have
two religious political parties that we
don't just have one we have two and so
so that argument has for now been lost
the argument that the public square
should be secular you you have
questioned Trump's sincerity in the area
of religion I do because I mean I just
think as I would Ronald Reagan's or as I
would anyone who
really doesn't go to church and all of a
sudden they get religion when they're
running for president so why do
evangelicals seem to love Donald Trump I
went to the Values Voter Summit yeah
here in DC a few months ago and Donald
Trump held up his personal Bible aloft
and the crowd went wild they loved it
they couldn't get enough of him and they
were less interested in a lot of the
other traditional candidates the more
the more establishment candidates and
here's a guy who's a gambling magnate
right a gambling tycoon yeah
twice-divorced what's going what's going
on for me the short answer is that one
effect of the culture wars has been to
make political identity the central
identity in American public life and for
much of American public life your
central identity has been your religious
identity I don't think that's true
anymore I think that now your central
identity is are you a liberal are you
conservative are you democrat or
republican
so as political as the cultures I've
driven political polarization and as the
parties have become more and more pure
made fewer and fewer moderates in the
Republican Party fewer and fewer
liberals in the Republican Party same
with Sam in the Democratic Party which
is becoming more purely you know liberal
center-left as that's happened the the
identity the political identity has
become really central so I would argue
that what what's happening with
evangelical support for Trump is they've
forgotten how to be Aven jealous and
they've become Republicans I argued the
same when I was talking about the Ground
Zero controversy and I saw him so few
Mormons come to the defense on religious
liberty grounds of Muslims which I
couldn't believe because Mormons are the
most persecuted religious minority in
American history how could they possibly
join in in the you know the gang fight
against Muslims and yet they were on the
ground zero mosque controversy and I
argued that they were forgetting to be
Mormons than they were they were they
had become Republicans first and I think
that's what's happened with evangelicals
I think that they read the Republican
party platform first and they read the
Bible second and so I'm trying to think
of ways we would actually diffuse a lot
of these culture wars kind of a
traditionalist about this I mean I think
we need to go back to religious liberty
back to the First Amendment back to this
idea that that our country isn't
simply to warring political parties
right our country is a bunch of citizens
who are trying to do things together in
our in our own public spaces and I think
that that tradition which I have
referred to as the great tradition of
conciliation in the United States this
tradition that argues for a kind of
civility in our public debates that that
argues for a sense of our awareness as
Americans rather than our sense of
awareness as Republicans or as Democrats
you know that is sort of failing and
that's been one of the one of the
victims of the contemporary cultural
wars but I think that that could be
revived and then the other thing is that
the hopeful piece in the book is that
these culture wars do end it's not like
it's not like they go on forever right
so even though the culture wars seem to
go on forever
we keep getting new cultural battles
inside them right so I think there's
reason to believe that the aslam are is
that we're in in right now you know
probably won't be happening in 50 years
you know the gay rights issue is
basically settled it's gonna in five
years they'll be gone the Republicans
aren't going to be complaining about it
in five years because it'll be just
stupid to do that so um there is some
hope that these things do do find the
end and then the values that the
Liberals have pushed in these wars
become just sort of American values
rather than you know democratic part of
the party values so last year in Indiana
when a gay people were I believe denied
service at a restaurant you came out
supporting religious freedom I think
that there's ways that we can have both
religious freedom and gay rights but
that requires some kind of accommodation
in the public space on both sides and
right now because the gay rights side is
winning it's really not eager to make
those accommodations but you know when
you do when you care about religious
liberty sometimes the religious liberty
is on behalf of minorities and sometimes
it's on behalf of majorities so and but
in your view the the principle holds the
same whether it's the majority of major
or the minority the whole point of
religious liberty protections this is
they is that where any any libertarian
protection is that they apply even when
we find the person's views or actions
disgusting right and in fact if if they
don't apply then then there
than there are non-starters right I mean
I'm in favor of the rights of you know
the Westboro Baptist Church to scream
out you know God hates [ __ ] wherever
they want to scream that out like that's
that's their freedom that's the kind of
country I want I want to I want to live
in you know rather than a country that
tells them that they're not allowed to
say that because it's an important view
Steven Prothero is the author the book
is why liberals win the culture wars
even when they lose elections Stevens
great to have you here for a reason TV
I'm Todd crane